star versus UK are you sure I've had him
since I was a kid really well good on
you
[Music]
hi I'm David Schwimmer and this is no
question no question I mean absolutely
no I've had those but yeah my wife Isaac
yeah because she's pretty smart he's a
genius
what are you taking the two best flavors
in the world peanut butter or chocolate
and putting them together so that's a
delight this is just one of the best
flavors out of these leaves and these
are basically Marmite flavored sort of
breadsticks oh yeah
oh yeah it's a Twinkie mini rose it a
breeze mini roll these it delicious I'm
tweaking a long time it's just it's like
a sponge with cream filling yeah I mean
nice oh yeah and a little bit smaller
more yeah I prefer I prefer that oh and
that's starburst original easly cold I
prefer ace nope never and there was a
rumor about nerds at primary school they
had glasses I mean I don't even need to
try I know which is better I know it's
starburst are American star versus UK
are you sure I've had him since I was a
kid
really I never knew they were UK well
good on you
now noise stop us
okay virgins
Virgil's root beer and what is this
hombre I mean that is delicious
[Music]
I mean that tastes like the dentist
I really want to try it now no no teslic
medicine in Sicily medicine and they
were the first one to you know no that's
better
really yeah yeah I don't know what that
is that is iron Bru some Scottish
underneath yeah even Scotland
it's not made by the people who do more
might know I mean I prefer this you
prefer that it's a draw this is Nick
Mohammed and this is David Schwimmer and
that was Boris for loud Bible
[Music]
you
[Music]